[Music]
did you guys know that we have a [ __ ]
podcast I bet you [ __ ] didn't that's
why your Dingle dangling around your
room [ __ ] jacking off to the wrong
[ __ ]
jack off the Bart's voice or Joe's voice
it'll help you and if you guys want to
know what those podcasts are you can
check in the description box below and
my friends make sure if you do like it
it was a nice little rating and if you
don't well you're obviously stupid party
time in killer B's news submitted by
Frank from Texas similar by Frank
I hope it's Franklin's barbecue I love
your hot sauce to a woman attacked by
bees was ignored because witnesses
thought she was on drugs
oh no it was she allergic as she died I
think if she was doing this [ __ ] there's
nothing people can't see what she's
probably in a downtown area yeah or is
it like the cartoons where they run from
one side and they went through the other
side well they're going to a light yeah
that's what my mom did she tried to
unlock the good cartoon literally cuz I
remember she had a broom and she's like
I'm gonna take this wall it was wasps
but it's like just watson us down I was
like I don't think I should do that mom
I think we should get an exterminator
she's like no I got this
and then I just hear walk out the door
and I hear smacks I think you should
like and then like she just quickly ran
back into the house and all the way she
gets done no kidding but you saw going
back and forth ha like a cartoon did you
guys have roses
we do have roses they like roses we have
roses too and we had like three or four
wasps nests all over the house they're
Chinese I just think my my dad loved
roses and I think they like the flowers
so they would just it would be all over
the house and I mean we don't have roses
of them anymore and we don't have any
watts so maybe all I know is that wasps
don't die to flush their flowers so just
to put that out there actually I'm a
really unsure right now amaretto sour
what stop harp is of those fools lost
eat what the [ __ ] she scared the [ __ ]
out of me wasps don't eat a honey and
like pollen is [ __ ] though right wasps
they eat like meat and [ __ ] baby
me I thought think I think they eat
flowers and stuff like Harlan if they do
man they don't have honey
they don't have honey but what's the
difference between a wasp and a
[ __ ] Hornet oh sure they they
hunt other insects yeah oh [ __ ]
gangsters like meet me and adult I don't
think wasps have stingers either they
fight so certainly wasp they catch
spiders yeah Wow
in high school I was eating a sandwich
and I was talking to my friends in his
[ __ ] wasp or Hornet landed on my
[ __ ] lip like oh and I froze can I
share hurt do like the way it was
crawling on my lip it was really
aggressive they thought your lip was
like a tempurpedic match at the ocean of
Hitler or some [ __ ] [ __ ] flu whales I
think when it was on the [ __ ] lip it
was crawling around like that
I should Doug it's little claws and [ __ ]
what sounds painful have you guys ever
seen a tarantula wasp or no is that
those [ __ ] are so [ __ ] big
so I saw one in Cape Town in our in our
back area and then me and Khalid had a
look at what we saw because we didn't
see it efforts we [ __ ] heard it it
was that loud it sounded like a toy
airplane [ __ ] screamed bro this
[ __ ] big they eat transyl's or some
[ __ ] where do they find tarantulas out
here I don't [ __ ] know maybe they
other things we have Walt that one next
to the finger let me see that [ __ ] these
things are [ __ ] huge oh my gosh oh
wow
you see that spear is the sign of a nail
that the nail huge oh that's from that
one guy that likes to [ __ ] roll
around and get stung by [ __ ] somebody
that's done by that [ __ ] he's like a
YouTube animal guy like he goes around
and [ __ ] it's so crazy so he gets
like red ants or stinger like [ __ ]
bees or whatever and he lets them [ __ ]
him up yeah that's the dumbest thing
I've heard in my life he's like crawled
like that [ __ ] Crocodile Hunter but
then like he's education on [ __ ] but he
just lets a lot of things [ __ ] him up
all the time because we had a Google
message because we didn't know what it
was we were just like big thing
blue whatever whatnot and then it was
that thing like a tarantula wasp and I
didn't know that I guess they're native
to here or something but that
[ __ ] was like this big I like
going to ice cream stores and letting
the ice cream [ __ ] my mouth up ice cream
store the ice cream store you guys are
curious we'll watch do they play a vital
role in protecting gardens and farm
crops by controlling pests populations
also the good guys well because they
control the population of the insect
repellent wash mess in my condo and I
got this wasp mommy think I killed all
of them I murdered the [ __ ] out in on my
balcony there's like a roof like the
work connects yeah right there fat Ness
I just saw them buzzing around ah so
where the [ __ ] is a [ __ ] Amazon this
thing we're gonna spray jets out like
eight feet ah kill them so good when I
was a kid I used to blast the [ __ ] out
of those Yellow Jackets so with the Hult
so instead of using a broom yeah I used
a hose and you could put it on the the
setting on like the stream so you blast
it where it's where you know it's always
connected by some little thin thing so
that thing falls then all the wasps come
up and they try to sting you then you
just blast them like you play on a
spaceship game and then you just see the
wasp come bail and just launch that full
backup yeah yeah I'm great
aim yeah I was pretty good as a kid all
right don't do that though kid that's
terrible why did it sound so exciting
yeah like a realized game when you're an
only child you have to anything ya
talkin either sibling guys for sure he
got dogs all right this story takes
place in Florida so this woman her
name's Sheena 24 years old she was
leaving her apartment and that's when
she was swarmed by all these bees that
she couldn't see so she could barely
hear over the buzz whoa in and out of
the road people thought that she was
crazy as she was on drugs and war that
honey perfume like she shouted help for
to a guy that was across the street he
was like no I don't want this dude
he's near me whoa down a little [ __ ] I
would have got a [ __ ] hair spray and
a lighter and I'll be like hell yeah
just walk around with hairspray and
lighter I'll run back in my house look
man I was like in a residential area so
you bounce I don't know how to help her
grab a hose at you a stress I would have
run away though I just be like stand
there stop drop and roll
oh that's fire sorry you gotta grab a
hose and blaster dies yeah so finally
this woman and her daughter recognized
her from the hotel that she works at so
they they started helping her by
spraying hairspray often how did she get
hair spray my idea is better and she
look good after a makeover and [ __ ] with
the be stuck on these in an attack damn
for hair spraying them hurry up but then
another guy came out and sprayed
something too
[ __ ] wd-40 that lady's getting
covered in chemicals and that [ __ ] got
cancer now dude straight up there's
gonna be a tumor on the side of her face
tomorrow kids come out with silly string
and [ __ ] be so bad just like I hate
crime now dude no [ __ ] taggers come
out with krylon and [ __ ] [ __ ] spray
paint
[ __ ] up this [ __ ] or what yup people
start kicking around the floor now it's
like it's a hate crime now dude pepper
spray painted batons any kind of spray
man got sprayed the [ __ ] down her
neighbor finally took her to the ER she
was stung about them the ass because she
got from all that all the townspeople
huh
what happened beat the [ __ ] beaver
yeah Savannah they saying that she got
stung on her arms head and face but she
was wearing long sleeves oh thank
goodness
thank goodness for her [ __ ] long
johns and then leggings so a lot of the
stains were on her scalp Oh God so she
got like a beehive head they got a
shaver I don't know you know what's
weird and you might not know the answer
to this but like you know how beekeepers
some [ __ ] can do this like no
problemo without any
like they just go in and I do that [ __ ]
but like why do some bees and groups
attack I got that answer so apparently
these bees were a large colony of about
7,000 Africanized bees oh no this is a
killer day yes so they're saying that
Africanized bees are super African
killer bees they're way more aggressive
and so with this bee expert was saying
that he believes that they were
originally mellow honeybees but then
their Queen may have left and mated with
an Africanized male and then over to got
that jungle fever
they all transitioned into a swarm of
aggressive bees you know what though all
bees are dying arguable [ __ ] we need
bees aggressive or not we need bees so
that lady just had to take one for the
team man what we need more bees you know
we got problems and [ __ ] like mad
probably no you got problems you know
that [ __ ] those PSAs on Bookface
definitely got me though because you
know they don't try and like save the
bees of [ __ ] every time I see a be
flipped over I'll flip that [ __ ] over
and I'll put a drop of water running
from and they drink that [ __ ] and they
fly away how cute yeah when the bees
flipped over it means it's dying it
looks like they're tired as well but
every time I've done it I flip them over
and cuz I go on that morning walk put a
little water on that [ __ ] they drink it
and they [ __ ] fly away Oh your own
thing it's not something else no no they
say like if you ate like a lot of bees
are dying from light because I don't
have water because of the drought that
really yeah so they're like give them
water and help them out yeah so many
problems and [ __ ] works dude we need
more bees in this world I'll be saving
bees dude you're a good man Thank You
Man thank you this is where those
Africanized bees were living it's
already been sealed up but they lived
inside of this crack here and you're
just a crack yeah and then they're
saying that now now that that the expert
he rescued the bees oh cool going to be
introducing reintroducing a new honey
bee queen so then over time they can be
back to wearing mellow where did this
happen Florida I thought you put the
beads into therapy and get them to
measure anger who should
and give me we gotta get all every but I
won't to lose but we need more bees oh
yeah we're gonna beat prices we don't
have enough bees they can't pollinate
our plants and [ __ ] we don't have food
man [ __ ] it I'll take a stinger to some
bees new haircuts - great you don't look
down bad head and they need like a nice
little bee fate to like meet the little
fuzz look nice
[Music]
you